let's talk about the five top health
tips of all
time someone suggested doing this on one
of my youtube videos
so i sat down and really took a look at
what would be the most important tips
that you should focus on to do that
i had to first look at the top
worst tips of all time okay which are
some of these right here
than to come up with the best tips it's
just a good way to figure things out by
looking at the opposite side
the problem that most people are running
into is that they're
they google stuff and they're trying to
find the best tips
but what they're going to get is either
the worst tips or
trivial things so what i want to focus
on
is the most vital things to produce the
most
health but mainstream talks about
doing low fat low salt drinking lots of
water
gallons of water now there's nothing
wrong with drinking enough water
but you could actually overdo it
especially if you're low on salt
because you're diluting your
electrolytes if you're drinking gallons
of water
now lean proteins people are brainwashed
to think that that's better than fattier
proteins but here's the thing
lean proteins will stimulate the hormone
insulin
okay which by the way this is the number
one
tip most of you already know this but
for those of you that don't
keeping your insulin levels normal is
probably the best health advice you can
give someone because
that's going to result in preventing
so many health problems from
inflammation to a fatty liver
to metabolic syndrome to blood pressure
to decreasing your risk of getting
cancer and the list goes on and on and
on
to do that you need to lower your carb
consume
fattier proteins because leaner proteins
on the insulin index will stimulate
insulin
more than fattier proteins
and that also includes consuming an egg
in its whole form
versus just the egg white now
vegetable oils as in soy oil corn oil
canola cotton seed are highly
inflammatory
and those could actually trigger insulin
resistance
so when you were taught that you had to
replace
saturated fats with vegetable oils that
is the worst advice
that you were given okay so we want to
get rid of the vegetable oils and use
more saturated oils
coconut oil fat from butter
things like that all right next one is
lose weight and get healthy
now if you look up pretty much any
health condition
regardless of what it is like heart
disease whatever they're going to tell
you you need to lose weight
you need to lose weight because obesity
is a risk factor
well number three this is better advice
get healthy to lose weight
first okay not lose weight to get
healthy
this right here might sound really kind
of simple and
almost like idiotically obvious
but it's very very powerful because
instead of focusing on your weight
you just focus on getting healthy and
guess what you will lose the weight as a
byproduct
but you also have a lot of other great
things as well
those people that are just so focused on
weight loss choosing the wrong program
that actually makes them unhealthy
especially if they've been given the bad
advice
of lowering your calories okay because
this is this is what they'll say right
here every diet works as long as you
keep your calories low
how many times have you ever heard this
very bad advice when you restrict
calories
you slow the metabolism and you also cut
nutrients
too if you get in a healthy eating plan
you increase your nutrients
and you change your fuel to the right
type of fuel
and you lose weight in a healthy way and
you look better
next one on the bad advice six small
meals per day
to prevent overeating
okay which is the worst advice because
every time you eat
you trigger insulin so fasting
is number two very very important
intermittent fasting
you need to skip your breakfast now i
used to be the guy that would recommend
consuming and breakfast well i found out
that was
bad information so i changed in my book
you don't want to consume
breakfast simply because you want to
increase your time of fasting it's going
to
really help you shift your metabolism
into burning your own fat
and you're going to be extremely healthy
if you do that and so instead of
lowering your calories
decrease the frequency of eating and
this one right here which is at the top
of the list you need to stop
snacking why because every time you
snack
you stimulate insulin so these two can
be pretty much combined but i wanted to
separate them
all right exercise well no that's a good
thing it's really good
but that would probably be down here
number six as far as a health
tip all right reduce your added sugars
now this is always interesting they tell
you to reduce your
added sugars to like six teaspoons of
sugar per day
well that's still going to be way too
high to get into ketosis because you're
still going to increase insulin so
why don't they just tell you to get rid
of all the sugars
so again it's it's advice but it's not
the best advice
in the world all right eat your
breakfast we already discussed that
how about this one there is no bad foods
you just have to eat variety foods foods
will give you
fuel this right here is probably
created by the food the junk food
industry
it is very bad advice because there are
bad foods
okay there are junk foods that will give
you some temporary fuel
but it's going to jack your insulin and
create all sorts of problems so there is
zero benefit in consuming certain
foods and that relates to this next one
a little bit
everything in moderation in order to get
into ketosis to get your body to burn
the right fuel which is fat
you have to bring the insulin down to do
that you have to bring your carbs down
on the low end okay so if everything's
in moderation you'll never get there
you want low carb moderate protein
so we can do moderate protein but higher
amounts of fat
okay that's the ratios that you need not
everything in moderation
so they're basically allowing you to
have everything in moderation
junk food sugar alcohol and you never
really get anywhere
with your health in order to get healthy
you can't have certain things in
moderation you must have them
very very low all right next one is no
one diet is for everyone
each person is different what works for
some people
might not work for someone else and so
that leaves you in a confused state
where you're trying diet after diet
after diet you keep trying to one day
maybe you'll find the right diet
well i disagree with this one right here
because
our bodies are very similar in certain
things
especially our hormones especially
insulin
any diet that helps you lower insulin
will help you any diet that helps you
lower insulin
will increase your health the diets
that lower it more are going to produce
more benefit those diets that raise
insulin are not
good diets and so if you understand the
back end of how fats burn and what
hormones do what
then you can actually predict what diet
is going to be
good or bad okay so we already talked
about this
we talked about that so number four
when you do a keto plan which is low
carb you want to do it healthfully and
what i mean by that
is you want to increase two things the
quality of
your ingredients you want to do organic
well caught
grass fed you also want to consume
foods that are high in nutrients that
satisfy
your nutrient requirement and so by
doing both of those
that is called healthy okay so healthy
keto
and keto is about getting your body to
burn ketones
which is the byproduct of fat so this is
number four
very good advice and number five
and number five we can include the
exercise and sleep
for all sorts of benefits as well as
reducing your stress okay so that would
be number five
and so when i really looked at
everything
these are the top five i couldn't think
of anything that was
higher in the list if you could think of
something that's better than these
five please put them in the comments
section below
before you go if you have a question
about a product or
you're new to keto and you want to know
how to begin keto
or you're on keto and you need a debug
because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you this is just for the people in
the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call but i put the
number down below
so you can call and get some help